[Music]
the betaf agog Galaxy launched a few
weeks ago and for those of you who don't
know it's a gaming platform much like
Steam but it's DRM free online and
feature optional and it's run by set up
react the same guys who make the which
up but can go galaxy really compete with
steam steam is far from perfect but some
of the reason valve gets away with their
F rated customer service award from the
Better Business Bureau is because the
platform has no real competition sure
there's the not so popular origin and
since we're all trying to forget you
play as a thing steam pretty much stands
alone in the market of digital games
platforms so they tend to get away with
whatever now though things could change
since GOG galaxy has come onto the
market with a lot of great promises
gog.com lets you purchase games
digitally and keep a record of your
games on this site but also have them on
your system without needing to use a
platform to access them
the lack of restrictions has been
received pretty favorably by gamers with
GOG games you download are a
self-contained package you can run it on
its own without ever having to
authenticate it with another online
service that means you can technically
just copy a game to a USB stick and give
it to all your friends to play whereas a
lot of services and publishers cling to
DRM to keep you from potentially ripping
them off like this set a proactive built
their company on the policy of trusting
their customers Gog's galaxy's hope to
draw gamers by letting them be as
involved or not involved in the platform
and its features as they like it
basically combines GOG coms DRM free
games with a Steam esque platform that
lets you add and connect with friends
automatically update games get
achievements and even play online with
Steam users all features are totally
optional in fact you don't even need to
install the GOG galaxy client to access
your games if you don't want to you can
just get everything straight from GOG
comm like normal
I'll speak to myself here since
everybody will have a different idea of
what kind of gaming platform works for
them I love the idea of dog galaxy but
will I completely abandon steam for it
probably not GOG does have an awesome
library of games you can't get anywhere
else
so this legacy is based upon preserving
old-school classic games that's now
extended towards featuring the cream of
the crop of triple-a and indie titles
both old and new while the library isn't
insignificant it certainly isn't its
enormous esteem staff says GOG is a
steadily growing site so if it's got a
lot of the good stuff from Steam + DRM
free games what's the problem personally
I had trouble embracing digital gaming
when steam first launched I avoided the
platform in favor of retail game copies
or DRM free digital games for as long as
I could but steam turns out to be a
really useful platform to chat with
friends and easily join multiplayer
games so I caved while I have a lot of
games from GOG and GamersGate they don't
come close to my massive stained library
and one of the most attractive reasons
to use a gaming platform is to have all
your games in one place so maybe you're
like me and have no intention of
ditching steam for good but God galaxy
could still be a really good thing even
if you have no intention of using it as
your primary games platform for one gog
frequently features deals just like
Steam so with any luck some healthy
competition is well on its way
despite the attractive drm-free game
selection on GOG Steam has had the
monopoly on gaming platforms for so long
and it's hard to convince people to
change most PC gamers are probably
plenty happy to put up with steams fault
though they can continue to enjoy its
fast library mod workshops trading cards
and other features that said for me
personally if I can get a DRM free deal
on GOG galaxy for a game that's also on
Steam I may well get it on GOG going
forward perhaps if enough people feel
this way and gold continues to offer
competitive prices the results will give
us
the gaming platform options on the whole
and at the very least it will force the
practically uncontested model if that is
steam to pick up their games those are
just my thoughts though so be sure to
let me know if you like the look of GOG
galaxy or if you prefer your steam
purchases to come through steam origin
or even you play a catch again soon
[Music]